sois we continue our discussion on DC
rebirth we pick up now with justice
league rebirth a state of fear now to be
honest with you guys I'm not really sure
what direction Brian hitch was going
with this the only thing I can deduce is
that because of the way the story arc
ends that he was looking to create a
shake-up in the roster of the Justice
League which kind of makes sense maybe
it was something a lot of lines what was
going on with Sam Humphreys Green
Lantern's but it seems as though you
know the the Justice League is maybe
going to substitute a new member or
simply just leave their roster the way
it is by the time the story ends I'm not
entirely sure but what this does is this
picks up with the Justice League
absolutely terrified for their lives now
we're not told what it is that they're
afraid of here we're not told or at
least what it is that you know what
what's invoking this fear all we know is
that something seems to be speaking out
regarding fear and it's absolutely
terrifying them now with regards to the
Justice League they're not scared of
whatever this entity is they're scared
of their own fears they're scared of
what it is in their lives that affects
them personally and this is really
interesting because of the character of
Jessica Cruz fear has always been a
major focal point of her character when
she was first created by Jeff Jones when
she was first introduced and over the
course republication history has always
been the idea that she was afraid of the
world she was afraid of everything out
there you know when she was elected to
become power ring and she was under the
influence of voloom from the from
earth-three fear was a major part of her
she never really believed that she had
the courage you know to to act in the
face of you know almost guaranteed death
you know with regards to her time on the
Justice League as a Green Lantern it was
the same thing that she always never
really saw a reason for why she was a
Green Lantern but was also interesting
about this is that initially in this
conflict because of the fact that Green
Lantern's have to overcome their fear in
order to be Green Lantern's that Simon
Baz and Jessica Cruz seem to be the only
two left now we're actually going to
find out the things aren't necessarily
as clear-cut as they seem to be here but
the indication from Brian hitch is that
because the Green Lantern's confront
their own fears and overcome their own
fears in order to combat the Sinestro
Corps especially that you know Simon
Badgers and Jessica Cruz are the only
two people here that can fort this
threat and this is actually what happens
as this fear begins to overcome them
they usually combine efforts as Green
Lantern's they overcome this fear and
they basically destroy it now again
whether Brian hitch is trying to use
this as like a metaphor for something
else I don't know really I
no clue where the story came from a why
was even written in the first place but
because of the fact that they're able to
pull the willpower of members of the
Justice League together and because
they're able to use their combined you
know character strength in order to
destroy this this fear that everything
seems to be right in the world now one
of the other interesting things about
this though is that Ryan hitch kind of
builds off the idea of the Justice
League just fighting an enemy there are
some times there are some cases when we
pick up with superhero stories where
right when the story starts
they finished fighting an enemy not
because that enemy is relevant but
because of the fact that it just shows
us here's what they were doing while
they were off panel and that seemed to
be the indication with this at least
that was my thought was Brian hitch is
just kind of showing us where here's
just what the Justice League was doing
you know while they were in between the
events of extinction machine and the
start of this storyline but the issue
with this is that again
Brian hitch I'm not really sure what
we're going but but another cool concept
misses some that I actually really liked
is Barry Allen and Jessica Cruz now my
thought was that with DC rebirth because
rebirth exists for the purpose of taking
what works before the new 52 and
combining it with what works in the new
52 though we would see Barry Allen in a
relationship with Iris West because that
was really a main focal point of his
character before you know the events of
the new 52 you know it was Barry Allen
or at least when he was alive anyway it
was Barry Allen and it was iris West you
know even really was before crisis on
Infinite Earths to be honest you know it
was Barry and iris and I'd always
thought that we were going to see a
return to their relationship because it
always just seemed natural and always
seemed appropriate that Barry Allen and
iris West were together you know they're
the DC power couple alongside Superman
and Lois Lane alongside you know
Marvel's spider-man and Mary Jane Watson
or spider-man and when Stacy if you're a
really old
you know Marvel comic fan but the fact
remains here that you know with this
situation instead Ryan hitch changes
things up and he actually has Jessica
Cruz ask Barry Allen out on a date now
to be honest with you guys I never
really saw an instance where Jessica
Cruz and Barry Allen would get together
just I mean I guess it works but it's
just weird to me right you know I mean
we we never would have seen Jessica Cruz
and Simon Baz get together that we know
that never would have happened
but I always thought that Jessica Cruz
would get together with someone who is
not a member of the Justice League like
just some random person you know like
Wonder Woman is Steve Trevor for example
you know or something along those lines
it would just be a random guy that she
met somewhere and just you know the two
of them just kind of hit it off and they
started dating I never really saw her
getting together with Barry
but it works it actually works really
well the chemistry between the two they
really bounce off each other and the
reason why I say that is for Jessica
Cruz because fear is such an art of her
life in terms of her backstory you know
when she's going through the process of
trying to figure out what to wear she
goes to the first State jitters you know
so she's trying to figure out what to
wear she's worried about well what if
Barry Allen doesn't like her when they
sit down what if it turns out to be the
most disastrous date ever and they can't
be friends anymore and then she has to
leave the Justice League because the two
of them just can't hit it off what
happens with that whole situation not
only that you know for Barry Allen it's
much the same way you know he gets the
first date jitters you know he goes home
he takes a shower after you know dealing
with different criminals and then it's
the same thing well maybe he you know he
feels like he's overdressed you know he
feels like he might come on too strong
he wants to get her flowers different
things like this and so ultimately the
two of them just kind of meet up and
they're both dressed casually now again
this is just a normal part of dating and
everybody gets that gets the nervous
jitters when it comes to the first dates
and what's also kind of funny as is
Brian hitch also keeps a little things
in touch with nothing just kind of cool
you know that when Barry Allen goes to
get her flowers because of the fact that
he was running he basically ran all the
petals off the flowers so Holly gives
her is a bouquet of stems which again is
kind of cute here but in even we end up
picking back up with with Batman and
Batman is bases just sort of sitting
around he tries to contact Dick Grayson
Dick Grayson doesn't answer and when
Alfred asked him if everything's okay
says he wants to be left alone now the
reason why this matters is because this
is very uncharacteristic of Bruce Wayne
Bruce Wayne does not usually let the
world know really let anybody know how
he feels on an emotional level he's very
guarded in that respect even with
members of the bat family the closest
members the ones that he's been
alongside of the longest you know when
it comes to Dick Grayson the longest
person that's been alongside his life is
part of the bat family you know Tim
Drake even Red Hood Jason Todd you know
for them it is that they always see him
as a member of the team but it's never
like a father-son relationship in the
true sense it's always a mentor and a
student relationship that's the way it
always is but to see Bruce Wayne you
know show his emotions even if he
doesn't speak it to basically show that
he just wanted to reach out to Dick
Grayson and see how he was doing tells
us tells us volumes about the fact that
something's going on that's affecting
Bruce Wayne on a personal level now from
here we jump back to
- Jessica Cruz and - Barry Allen and
this is again Brian hitch telling us
that there's something going on under
the current here of course there are a
couple funny moments you know when Barry
Allen orders a ton of food because as a
flash he has to eat so much stuff but as
soon as he goes to touch the hand of
Jessica Cruz she freaks out she
absolutely loses her mind and just flies
into a state of hysterics and is
completely overcome by fear and what
Brian hitch is telling us here is that
this sense of fear that the members of
the Justice League were experiencing at
the beginning of the story has not gone
away that for some reason they're being
infected by absolute terror that the the
worst fears of them at the particular
moment in time are coming to fruition
and so Jessica Cruz does exactly what
she did when she you know saw her
friends murdered during her introduction
and she runs into a safe room and she
just refuses to leave and so what we do
is we jump to Superman and we have
Superman speaking with Lois Lane now
what he says is that he basically has a
headache you know that for whatever
reason is his head's bothering him but
but you know the more he talks to Lois
Lane the more he reveals that he's angry
you know when she initially brings up
the fact that Superman is trying to earn
the trust of Batman he initially lashes
out and says don't don't talk about him
you know and in the two of them get into
somewhat of an argument in the sense
that he says you know Superman makes the
case that he's tried to save the world
so many times he's tried to earn
Batman's trust so many times and Batman
still won't trust him and so ultimately
he says the only thing left for him to
do is to go find Bruce Wayne and to kill
him and so what this does is this of
course inevitably leads to a conflict
between Batman and Superman now for
those of us who have been reading DC
Comics so really if you've been reading
for any measure of time especially with
the new 52 there's a general rule of
thumb when it comes to reboots or it
comes to soft reboots or rehashing of
character story arcs if in any situation
Batman and Superman or any variation of
their characters have met for the first
time they will fight if it's an else
world story like The Dark Knight Returns
you know they fight in that story that
really set the stage for Batman vs
Superman the two of them fighting one
another when the new 52 first started
they fought one another and Elseworlds
stories when they meet for the very
first time they fight each other it's
just a general rule and this is no
different because DC rebirth effectively
sees the crossover of the pre new 52
Superman into the new 52 landscape in
order to take the place of the new 52
Superman who's now dead
this is effectively
at least what seems to be the first time
these two are meeting now something to
keep in mind here is that Bruce Wayne
does not know about what's going on with
a larger story arc in the fact that you
know 10 years were taken from their
lives so on and so forth he doesn't know
all that stuff you know for him it's
just this is a new Superman and so it
still allows for Brian hitch to create a
scenario where the two of them fight one
another not only that whenever you have
a story where Batman a Superman fight it
always just does well everybody just
loves seeing Batman and Superman fight
one another and this is exactly what
happens Superman shows up in the Batcave
you know after breaking through a wall
or smashing through a wallet tells Bruce
Wayne look I've done every single thing
that you've asked you know I traveled to
the core of the earth which we saw him
do during Instinct extinction machine
you know he says I was willing to give
up my family if I had died in the
process and that would have been in no
one would have been there to take care
of Jonathan and and Lois Lane he's you
know he says I was willing to put my
life on the line for the sake of
following your orders trusting you and
saving the world and you still don't
trust me you know what does it take and
so at this point Superman is in truth
just ready to kill Batman but this is
again because he's being punched towards
the direction of fear now from here we
jump to Wonder Woman and Aquaman with
Wonder Woman and Aquaman you know
they're basically again because they're
friends you know she's helping him with
the task of pulling you know a giant
tanker out of the ocean and the more
Aquaman and Wonder Woman start to talk
the more they begin to say things like
they're getting irritated with humanity
you know Aquaman says that humanity is
constantly poisoning the waters of the
oceans you know of his domain with you
know toxins and with ships and so on and
so forth and Wonder Woman says that she
was sent outside of Amazon for a mission
of peace you know she was sent outside
into the realm of men in order to bring
peace to the world but she says that
people are just inherently violent and
it seems that from her perspective the
only way to solve this problem is to
just kill everyone or at least take over
the world you know that way people will
people will live in peace whether they
want to or not that they live in peace
with with a gun pointed to their head
basically and so this trend continues
following this you know Ryan hitch
continues to take us on this journey
where you have cyborg who talks about
how he believes that he is he's deformed
you know that he's screwed up he doesn't
like people seeing him for what he is
you know he's paranoid to the fact that
everybody's looking at him you know for
Simon bass he just wants to be left
alone that he doesn't think anybody will
accept him he doesn't think the Justice
League likes him he feels isolated so
again Ryan hitch is just bouncing back
and forth Batman and Superman are in the
conflict of fighting one another
their battle is very very quick and the
reason why is because for Bruce Wayne
his intellect his intelligence is at the
top of the list you know when it comes
to some of the most intelligent people
in DC Comics and for him he knows enough
about himself he knows that if he
allowed his guilt to override him that
he would rather insane that he would not
be able to be an adequate superhero and
so the fact that his guilt is at the
surface because of the fact that he now
feels bad or I guess you know he's
allowing his guilt to play more of a
role in his life you know in terms of
controlling him regarding the death of
Jason Todd by you know the hands of the
Joker the death of his parents at the
hands of Joe Chill indicates to Bruce
Wayne that somebody or something is
manipulating him that something's
happening whereby their fear is being is
allowing to take control and so once
Superman comes to this realization to
the question they have is what happens
next now with regards to this continued
journey of Jessica Cruz again Brian
hitch really plays on her character and
if I can be honest with you guys I love
the idea of Jessica Cruz but I really
feel like it's time to let go of this
fear element and move into something
else because this really seems to be the
backbone almost every single story that
we see with her character it's always
I'm never going to be a good Green
Lantern no one ever trusts me I can
never be a real superhero why am i
agreeing Lantry it's always the same
thing and granted it's great for
creating a good dichotomy between who
she is as a Green Lantern and who she
used to be and it's great for providing
a weakness to her if you were to go
against like the Sinestro Corps but the
fact remains here that I think it's time
to start moving beyond the fact that
Jessica Cruz is just afraid of
everything and start focusing on making
her a more empowered character but Brian
hitch follows this trend of focusing on
her fear granted this story is designed
to focus on fear so it makes sense you
know but the idea is that for both Barry
Allen and for Jessica Cruz that their
fear is totally overcoming of them you
know Barry Allen initially tries to talk
her out of it he tries to reason with
her but again you know Jessica Cruz is
totally succumbed by not only that she
begins to vomit up what looks like this
fear substance or liquid or something
like that and it seems to incapacitate
Barry Allen so while this is happening
again we get this sort of disembodied
voice talking about how all these all
these members of the Justice League are
succumbing to their fear all these
members of the Justice League are weak
at their core and that you know whatever
this entity is is going to take over the
Justice League and in turn seems like
it's going to lay waste to the planet as
a whole and so what happens is this
massive embodiment of fear begins to
make its way throughout the entirety of
New York
and Batman and Superman begin to again
have this conversation on what's going
on Bruce Wayne and Superman sort of sit
down and have this discussion they
essentially say or at least Bruce Wayne
has come down and says you know look I
can't always trust you it's just I don't
work that way more so than that he says
that we're not the exact same kind of
people you know you come from a family
of hope you know your family was dying
and your parents sent you away from a
dying planet believing that you could
live out you know it was the hope that
he would survive and continue on the
legacy of their race even if it meant
they couldn't continue their race
through procreation at the same time
Batman is a family of tragedy his
parents were murdered
since lessly there was no real reason
behind it and so it wasn't some
grandiose scheme it wasn't leading to
something incredibly beautiful and great
like Superman instead it was just Batman
doing what he could with the hand that
he was dealt and ultimately you know
allowing Bruce Wayne to step into the
Batman mantle and so he says they're not
the same kind of people they come from
two different worlds the reason behind
their existence is totally separate but
for Superman he says that doesn't matter
but the two of them needed to learn to
accept each other they have to trust one
another because it's the only way that
they can fight adequately as superheroes
and so what happens is that ultimately
this all really just comes down to
Jessica Cruz I thought I was going to
come down to some great big huge
grandiose conflict I thought it was
going to be another battle with the
Justice League but that doesn't happen
instead you know it really just seems
like Ryan hitch was focusing a lot on
the characters you know Brett you know
Batman is Superman coming to grips with
one another on who they are
cyborg coming to grips with his own fear
sign in Bath's coming to grips with who
he is as a person and where he belongs
this story's great for character
development but the reason why I say it
kind of felt like he was out of nowhere
is because suddenly they're afraid and
then they're not you know and and
Jessica careers of course uses the power
of her Lantern ring to destroy that
concept of fear but it was good for what
it was in terms of us having a better
understanding of the characters but
beyond that it seemed a little strange
and so ultimately you know I guess as
the story begins to wrap up
Jessica Cruz basically says that she's
gonna carry on to be a Green Lantern
she's going to continue that role but
she doesn't know if she wants to be in
the Justice League anymore the reason
why she says that is because as she felt
his entity go through her you know she
felt as this creature go through her
that they gave her a sense of an idea
that she's just not ready for that yet
you know she's simply just not ready to
be a member of a team
again as the Justice League now this is
Brian hitch telling us just how
important the Justice League is the
Justice League is not the Titans the
Justice League is not the teen titans
the Justice League is not you know
Justice League International or
something like that you know it's not
Doom Patrol it's none of that stuff the
Justice League is the premier team of DC
Comics the premiere protectors of the
planet Earth when all else fails the
Justice League is there and they will
die fighting an enemy to protect the
earth it's just the nature of who they
are that comes with a massive amount of
responsibility and Jessica Crewe's being
so easily overcome by fear and having to
fight with every inch of her life in
order to protect the members of her team
and the world is simply a responsibility
that she's not ready yet but note this
take note of this she was the only one
who did she was the only one that saved
the world the rest of the Justice League
was totally overcome with fear Batman
and Superman were talking about their
problems
you know Barry Allen was there with her
but Simon Baz was contemplating his
problems and cyborg was sitting around
contemplating his problems
Jessica Cruz was the one who acted to
save people she was the one that acted
to save the world and so ultimately if
there's anyone that's part of the
Justice League right now who should be
part of that team it is her and so the
question that I have I guess at the end
of this is what's Ryan hitch going to do
with her maybe it was that Sam Humphreys
wanted to take her in a direction
totally isolated maybe it's because you
know Brian hitch wants us you know focus
on her outside of the Justice League we
don't really know at this point but what
we do know is that at this moment right
now
Jessica Cruz has officially left the
team but with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you guys are
new here too the two comics explained
that she you guys did the sub button
become part of the rock court and if you
guys want to see some more DC we birth
stuff that makes you guys drop a like
and leave a comment down below let me
know what you guys think and I will
catch you all in it please
[Music]